the coronavirus pandemic is having a
huge impact on the restaurant business
including fast
food giants like mcdonald's the company
announced this week that global sales
were down nearly 24 percent
last quarter mcdonald's plans to close
about 200 stores here in the u.s
and it just unveiled new initiatives to
tackle the pandemic
and racial injustice including measures
to address hiring bias
only on cbs this morning president and
ceo kris kamchinski
joins us from mcdonald's global
headquarters in chicago mr tim
kamchinski thanks for being with us uh
and thanks for joining us i wanted to
ask you to start off by explaining what
the new initiatives are
what we just announced yesterday to our
entire system it was uh 12 000 people
joined us across 93 countries
uh was refreshing our company values
these are values that started with ray
kroc
65 years ago and it's something i
believe very
uh passionately about as a leader and so
we announced
uh a set of values five values uh one of
which
as you mentioned in the in the opening
uh was around diversity inclusion so
that's what we announced yesterday
so uh part part of the uh these ideas
came
from your own experience on a global
listening tour of
of mcdonald's workers what did you hear
that surprised you
i think what i don't know if it was a
surprise so much is just
a reaffirmation about how important it
is for us to be talking about values
uh whether it was down to the crew
person all the way up to
my senior team uh there's there's a
strong desire for us to be talking about
values because it's a common vocabulary
it's
it's something that across the globe we
have two million people that work in the
mcdonald's system
uh when we talk about values it sets
expectations
and it ensures that all of us are living
up to those so i think just for
me what i heard on the listening tour
was just a reminder about how important
it is for us to continue to reinforce
the values because it's what
makes mcdonald's such a special company
what specifically will you try to change
and how will you ensure that it actually
happens
i think across all the the values for me
what we're trying to do is just make it
more
part of how we're operating on a
day-to-day basis so one of the values is
about
keeping our uh people and our customers
first
and that in the case of the pandemic
right now is all about safety and
and so we're spending a lot of time
right now in our restaurants making sure
we can keep our crews safe making sure
we can keep our customers safe but i
think the thing about these values is
they're enduring they're not something
that's just a moment in time they last
for 65 years
we just use them to animate our actions
uh as a situation arises so right now
we're dealing with a pandemic and we've
got a set of initiatives there
uh that i've been very proud of how our
systems responded you're now requiring
masks in restaurants
yes we are and and when did you make
that decision
that was a decision that we made last
week uh and that was requiring it for
customers we've actually for for quite
some time required our crew to wear
masks
but we thought that it in light of what
we're seeing it's prudent now that we
also ask our customers
to wear masks in the restaurant as well
and how are you planning to enforce that
we've done a whole training with our
crew in restaurants
about expectations and how to work
with customers and explain to customers
why we have
uh the requirement to wear a mask the
the thing i'm pleased to announce uh
or talk about is is one week into this
the vast vast majority of customers are
more than willing
to wear a mask i think the vast majority
of people the vast majority of americans
understand why it's important to be
wearing a mask
in the event that we do have someone
who's unwilling to wear a mask we've
also done training around de-escalation
but ultimately
we're not going to be asking our crew
people to put themselves in harm's way
if someone is unwilling to wear a mask
and comply with
with our rules that might be where we
might bring in law enforcement
all right the nation reported this week
the magazine the nation that uh
mcdonald's employees
uh scores of women who work at
mcdonald's have accused the company of
fostering a culture
of sexual harassment and actually
punishing workers
uh for speaking out what are you doing
to address these allegations
i think anytime you hear about something
like that it's disturbing it certainly
goes against
everything that that we stand for as a
company everything that i want us to be
doing uh
around diversity and inclusion so the
first thing is
when you hear about a situation like
that it's to go in and find out what
went wrong
and we need to make uh fixes quickly in
those situations we need to understand
how do we do better
and for me this goes back to values
we're going to continue to reinforce
set of expectations one of which is
around everybody should be able to come
to mcdonald's and contribute
and it should be nothing based on more
than the job that they do
here and so there's no place for uh the
situation that you described and we will
address it
um you you're facing dozens of legal
complaints do you believe you have a
you have a problem of workplace
harassment
i'm i'm proud about how our our company
and our crew
uh in our franchisees uh how we treat
people you don't get to be
a brand and a business the size of
mcdonald's without
treating people well being a good
employer but
in a system of our size you will have
situations that
like of which you're talking about there
again when those situations crop up it's
important for us to acknowledge them
address them
and do everything we can to learn from
it and so as ceo that's certainly what
i'm committed to make sure it happens
all right chris kimchimski ceo
mcdonald's thank you so much for being
with us